il ya eu une entente de cessez-le-feu en
ukraine en février dernier mais depuis
quelques jours les escarmouches se
multiplient entre troupe ukrainienne et
rebelle pro russe
ces dernières heures six soldats
ukrainien et un rebelles ont trouvé la
mort les principaux affrontements se
déroulent dans la région de l'aéroport
de donetsk aux mains des insurgés depuis
janvier dernier pour rassurer les
autorités ukrainiennes qui ont perdu
beaucoup de terrain depuis le début de
cette guerre des américains les
britanniques ont déjà envoyé des
véhicules militaires et des instructeurs
pour former les troupes gouvernementales
aujourd'hui c'était au tour du canada
d'annoncer qu'il allait aider l'ukraine
et j'annonce que les forces armées
canadiennes participeront à
l'entraînement des soldats ukrainien de
la police militaire ukrainienne pour
qu'ils puissent mieux défendre la
souveraineté de leur pays
les canadiens vont enseigner entre
autres la neutralisation des mines et
des explosifs
en plus de fournir une formation
médicale et d'entraîner la police
militaire le chef du npd thomas mulcair
croit que monsieur harper aurait dû
d'abord consulter le parlement et tous
les autres pays membres de l'otan elle a
l'obligation de parler avec les
canadiens à travers leurs élus au
parlement il a l'obligation de
travailler avec nos alliés
parce que s'il arrive quelque chose de
malheureux et on le souhaite pas
évidemment ben là il n'aura que lui même
à blâmer les canadiens devraient rester
loin de la zone des affrontements à
l'est de l'ukraine et sont basés dans
l'ouest du pays notamment dans la région
de yavo rives
la mission des soldats canadiens
devraient prendre fin le 31 mars 2017
dans ce pays où la guerre a déjà fait
plus de 6000 morts et où deux millions
d'habitants ont dû fuir leurs foyers et
raymond l'a déjà une première réaction
du côté de la russie
oui dénommé viatcheslav nikonov lui il
préside la commission parlementaire sur
l'éducation à la douma le parlement
nul doute que ce qui est lundi reflète
vraiment la position du régime de
monsieur poutine il a dit que le canada
va mettre jeter de l'huile sur le feu et
aider les troupes ukrainienne a tué plus
de civils c'est quand même assez grave
comme accusations et dit que la
situation actuelle est bien pire que ce
qui se passait pendant la guerre froide
parce que pendant la guerre froide avait
pas trouvés
nadine en ukraine encore moins de
troupes américaines ou britanniques
il y accuse le canadien reproche le
canada de suivre aveuglément les états
unis plutôt que de tenter de chercher à
la demande pacifique à ce conflit
bon alors vous le disais les canadiens
vont être là pour un peu moins de deux
ans et demi vont vraiment un peu pour
rassurer peut faire acte de présence
mais ils vont être loin la zone des
combats
pourtant on en ukraine la situation
continue de se détériorer exactement
depuis ces derniers jours surtout depuis
dimanche j'ai eu de nombreuses
violations du fait des accords de
cessez-le-feu de février dernier
plusieurs affrontements plusieurs
endroits
chaque côté et reproche à l'adversaire
de ne pas avoir retiré toutes ses armes
lourdes
loin de la ligne de cessez-le-feu donc
de les utiliser pour bombarder et hier
soir à berlin
les quatre ministres des affaires
étrangères des pays qui ont piloté ces
accords de ces négociations de
cessez-le-feu donc la france l'allemagne
l'ukraine et l'ue s'ils sont dits très
inquiété par la dégradation de la
situation là bas et on demandait aux
deux côtés de faire encore plus que ce
qui s'était engagé à faire c'est à dire
de votre tir encore plus d'armes loin de
la ligne de cessez le feu pour calmer le
jeu évidemment c'est les deux courtes on
arrive mal à respecter ce qu'on s'est
engagé à faire on voit mal comment on
pourrait faire encore plus que ce qu'on
a promis alors c'est à suivre
et vous allez continuer le suivre tout
ça pour nous mais c'est vraiment de vue
et si vous voulez voir où sont postés
les militaires canadiens à l'étranger je
vous invite à consulter notre dossier
web vous voyez l'adresse à l'écran